Цю дівчину витягли рятувальники після обстрілу пологового будинку в Маріуполі.
Її доправили до найближчої лікарні.
Вагітна розуміла, що втрачає дитину.
Тому благала медиків убити її. Імені дівчини лікарі так і не дізналися.
У той день, коли бомбанули пологовий, до нас привезли трьох.
Одна найтяжча була з розчавленим тазом і відривом правого стегна, в шоці.
Поки її реанімували, проводили протишокові заходи, ми зробили кесарів розтин, дістали дитину без ознак життя.
Протягом більш ніж півгодини реанімація дитини не дала результатів.
Потім ще півгодини чи більше реанімація матері - без результатів. Загинули обидві.
У цій лікарні на околицях Маріуполя струм з генераторів іде лише в операційні.
Віднедавна тут приймають і пологи. Світла, тепла, води, їжі немає, як і у всьому місті.
- Це що, з літаків?
- Та з літаків, мабуть…
Тут народжувала і Маріанна. Вона живою вибралася зі зруйнованого обстрілом пологового будинку.
Це та сама дівчина у піжамі "в горошок", фото якої побачив увесь світ.
Однак у Росії історію Маріанни назвали "фейком".
Це сталося дев'ятого числа в третій лікарні в Маріуполі.
Ми лежали в палатах, і в нас повилітали вікна - скло, рами, і всі ненесучі стіни.
Ми не знаємо, як це сталося.
Дівчина народила доньку Вероніку. Мати та немовля здорові.
А це підвал пологового будинку в Києві.
Медики роблять усе, щоб мати змогу працювати навіть під час обстрілів.
Ночують під землею разом із пацієнтками. А молодим мамам у підвалі доводиться народжувати.
Тут реанімаційна палата, тут діти.
Якщо після операції або складних пологів, то вони залишаються тут, під наглядом лікарів у цій кімнаті.
Вона у нас… І пологи ми тут приймаємо, і якщо операція, і діти, якщо треба нагляд.
Маленький Максим денне світло бачить уперше.
Він народився в підвалі раніше строку.
Поки в небі над столицею тихо, малюк із мамою Наталею насолоджуються спокоєм.
Наталя каже, що тут, у пологовому, почувається в безпеці.
Коли війна почалась, і "швидкі" взагалі перестали їздити, то це страшно, дома взагалі не хочеться якось…
Машини немає, "швидкої немає", не знаєш куди бігти, не знаєш, що робити. Оце страшно.
А тут уже лікарі поруч, медсестри поруч, допоможуть.
Персонал пологового підтримують жителі Києва - хто чим може. Лікарям це додає сил.
Люди приходять, приносять хлібину чи цукерки для дітей.
Навіть не називаючи своє ім'я приходять, залишають на охороні просто для співробітників,
просто для лікарів, які тут зберігають спокій цих жінок,
тому це дуже приємно і такий народ подолати не можна ніколи.
Ще одна молода мама Аліна приїхала до Києва з Ірпеня за кілька днів до пологів.
Тоді в містечку вже починалися бої. Нині дівчина не знає, чи цілий її будинок.
Утім, радіє своїй крихітці.
Доньку назвала Василісою, каже, що дівчинка в неї "бойова". Ще й народилася восьмого березня.
Усе в порядку, все гаразд. Єдине ось, я кажу, що оці літаки…
Читаю новини - у Маріуполі, якщо не помиляюся, на пологовий будинок скинули бомбу.
Там такі кадри, як надивилася, то вже, як-то кажуть, хочеш чи не хочеш, а лежиш і слухаєш, є сирена чи ні.
Тим часом у Маріуполі попри жах і розпач на світ з'являється нове життя.
Давай-давай, ніжки, ніжки!
Вона пережила зруйнований третій пологовий будинок, їх розбомбили, привезли до нас.
Вони стільки пережили з мамами, всі породіллі, хто тут…
Перший крик крихітної Алани ненадовго заглушив звуки обстрілів.
У такі моменти емоцій не стримують ані породіллі, ані медики.